So my problem right now is it's sending the
resume messageTo the.
To the DiscordAnd.
It needs to be sending
Money
Tomorrow
I don't want you anyways
With salad in it
What's up
You know the momentHe start going through
with the security license.
You need to help him to get the rest of the
way which is going to probably just be the
fingerprints
Yeah you got to sign up for the appointment
or something then I can gone all dayOh okay
well I didn't know what you meant.
Like
Fingerprints nothing cuz even you could go
get a level two
And that shooters
That's all I'm saying Allied pay like 13 to
15 dollars an hour and I was in an office
Aria or what was doing in that office
Watching the security be the security and
illegal people who not trying to get caught
doing illegal shit
You'll take the flag for itUp here and say a
session.
With me yeah that back in My Level 2 days
that's why I say you going to be at level 2
you ain't got to
YouTube
PlayStation is having a free online
multiplayer weekend
I think that's this weekendWhich means. You
probably could play online for free.
On games likeWhich one did you pick.
I chose pick for me because I never watched
it so I just said pay for meAnd then tell
you.
Sorry
I won't have 21 I just pick for me
Till 12 SundayUntil they end up tomorrow.
Also you going to be playing some Call of
Duty now
I said I
It's Emily upset about it
Ain't that a shame
I'm
Vietnam WarBehind it up over there in the
first place.
YeahNo outside.
Better have no bad dancer
What's up what's upPlease.
Ain't no way okay
If
You don't have to hit me
If you close to me start thinking about your
moves then when you spaced out you can stand
again
You feel like bringing them to me
?
And I just died
I didn't make waterfall
Are we at I don't know if she didn'tIt's a
bowl right here.
That I put right next to youAin't no way you
missed it.
Good morning
No way
Welcome
Cuz I should be able to hit that move
without getting you
No
Bunch of helicopter
You want to do itNow I want to do that.
Free you have to pay for the camera
The girl who made the video put in the
comments
That she said that she sells the camera
But it and then you get a free charm in
bedazzle stuff but if you have your own
camera and come up there then you can get
the bedazzle and the charm for free
overnight but 33 minutes away from here I'm
not driving 33 minutes
Unfortunately
Respond to
Even when you get frustrated in the game I
think I need you to think about me
If I'm on the side that you're attacking you
need to be thinking about what you do
We are at the peak of our abilities running
let's play like the peak of our ability
I think I got way too much advantage over
there on the edge bro
To
It's frustrating
It's frustratingCuz where's my.
No cuz when you're on the edge like maybe
you got to see what it feels like
I couldn't do that before
I'm all the way on the corner though though
like on some shit
Hey you got me into it with all that
laughing
I just didn't expect you to be so bad but I
can react like it doesn't matter how fast
you got I just didn't expect you to leave so
fast that was it it was just a shot and then
after that it was like okay
But I don't know if she'll happen about that
that was the craziest part about it was the
laughter for me
Remind you I still haven't gotten serious
notice this is still a lot of down triangles
Johnson
But you got better
Oh better than me
I think I'm
Anybody like that come on
Poop hey you didn't close to me
But you make me definitely not want to
Play the game with you I mean like you make
me not want it like
Joking kids we got to get a game of zombies
in for Carmen call me want to play some
zombies on
All right but after after whenWait wait
never mind. Y'all can play online zombies.
It's PlayStation Plus all weekend
Thinking about him
Want to see if that online work it's online
don't work I want to play if it didn't work
I don'tI rather I play online.
I cannot believeIt is already. 8:00.
And I'm just not getting back to the
computer
Do you need the that black controllerI'm
asking can I get my cord back.
You can toss itIf you can toss.
Homie did you not hear me you can only play
two players online
If you play if you complain online I don't
want to play so y'all can play online
Cuz it's already 8:00 and you got until
12:00 tomorrow not to be able to play online
for free number
Oh this guy has 40 oh my God oh my God
We might as well just keep these guys on the
board cuz these guys going to be forever
All right did anybody join the chat while
the agents have been running of course not
that's okay and in the personal stream
nobody ever shows up so
We just going to start doing a way better
job of expressing ourselves whether or not
somebody is hearing I should be able to
gather my thoughts and explain my project at
any given point and let people know what the
agents are doing and working on
Right now the biggest thing is I need to get
Well to be honest with you the only agents
that are working the way that I would
personally prefer we are agents one seven
and eight and I need to get the other I said
one but I meant three seven and eight I need
to get agents the other agents up and
running and I'm going to start with agent
one
Who was working onService consolidation.
So let's see what they did
Status update on the service consolidation
we got six services to migrate 100% complete
the portfolio service complete and verified
the AI service complete and verified the
Thea service complete and verified the
unified messaging service complete and
verify which is crazy because why do I have
a unified and a Consolidated so we need to
ask questions like let's see
Both electrical
Oh I think for him it's a square
Are you getting levels
You want to know why you didn't beat me on
my bro holler
Because you found something that worked and
thought it was going to keep working the
whole timeI understand.
ButYou got to understand I'm going to adapt
to it.
And then the longer we play without you
trying to adapt your strategy right trying
to hit it faster than me
That's not going to work I've already at
that point I already have a plan so whenever
it does work I know what's going ahead and
do that's why the wind started getting more
cleaner for me
You want to know the counterWhat would have
thrown me off.
Weapon throwsCuz you don't throw your weapon
okay.
ThanksCuz you never fake so I know if you
come near me I need to dodge.
And switching it up it will will fix that
thing
That comes with just learning more things so
you learn some good shit
You know I'm not saying you did bad like I'm
saying this is the best you've ever played
Nobody none of my kids make me feel like I
felt that first life
You knowBut.
But then you also activatedMy inner
competitive side with the laughing.
RightI don't care how good you got it. Until
the end of the match you ain't one.
And don't act like it until serious match
they don't be talking in the championship
match
That shit serious as hellAnd you treat me
like the God damn final boss.
I was thinking about that being my name but
it was too long
The boss that pop out after the top boxNo
but top floor boss.
You hear meTop floor boss like the top.
Yeah I like the top floor bossThe boss from
the top one not the top floor.
Yeah
Yeah I still got that right
Phone or something
Online
I ain't onlineY'all playing the wrong game
right now. It's four players.
Tomorrow we playing a little bit planetCuz I
got to get cold in there and I can't I can't
but oh my God.
If we didn't just play like 4 hours of
fucking brawhala
I swear to God I'll hop down some little
I got enough time to smokeFinish closing up
these agents.
Let them run overnight so hopefully I can
wake up in the morning and beA millionaire.
No soAbout.
A lot lot lot lot light like like Carmen why
you think your uncle be willing to put you
on cuz that little 16,000 you think you're
not going to give me bro 16,000 ain't going
to be nothing to you you become a pilot
You're not looking and it gotStart only
ones. Don't think about this opportunity.
No the only thing that's going to suck for
you is how you going to get thereCuz that
shit normally near the airport.
You live with somebody that don't like to
drive
But if I'm paying 16,000 the least that
could do is fly you home
But in total I'm paying $16,000 I feel like
if I'm paying no no and told us 16,000 got
to be paid tuition say 16,000 got to be paid
so it don't matter what they say when you
become a pilot I'm beholding the 16,000 over
your head for your whole life
So you going to have a 60,000 did you not
hear me it's not like I'm asking you to give
me my $16,000 back
Call meThat's the way inflation works.
Tomorrow
I don't get
It's actually better will be closed cuz we
got to be in the house just going to do
SomethingShit.
Supposed to do
Oh I didn't know that
Reload and I still don't know
Japanese
How Charlie
It's like
I'll download it but it isOkay.
Before night and cookingFortnite at cooking
in. I can't wait for it. Just wanted to
play.
Yeah but we need kids soft controllersTo be
a fucking.
Say for yourself
Minecraft Escape
But he's talking you can shop right here
You pick it up with it you put it down with
eggs and you press the square to drop it
You know
I want to dishwasher away over there
This is pregnant
He picked up the other one you got to get
To sleep now
Bro
Maybe it's the kitchen set upI think so too.
Cuz all this moving
Yeah this is the next level we change it
from yesterday
Like 7:40
A.m.
Elsewhere in western Michigan
More cheese
For me
Bro
Buns you got a whole burger right here
Got a brown sugar
No you were supposed to go in there bro
Because this one just because
Cheese so you can turn
Come on Carmen bro we got to start over we
need something 760
?
Girl
Wait is cheese
Mark come on we almost done
Now
There's
Put up on his plate
Give me that bleed in a bun
You're dealing with a knife and chopped
cheese tomato and possibly some pepperoni or
chicken
You cut it right here
I'm just making sure
The thingMake sure we got everything.
Else
Right here it's only one
Up a little bit moreAbout you too.
Plano cheese no cheese torchino
The place
I guess they only start with oneLOL.
Comma you said I left the plate bro when she
got to go back to youNow we can't get to the
tomatoes.
Okay
If you can can you bring me a tea tomorrow
so
If you can water works too
If somebody
Where is it down here
Excuse
No cover not nothing to do like thatSay it.
You're welcome
Don't listen
No
Not to get a home
Especially
What did you say
I said that I think I need something even
smaller I think the hole is like it's really
small
NoThe horrible idea.
That will not take the Patrick leave it
alone
So now there's hole in itYou know we leaving
this on tonight.
Was